are you tired of investing time and
money into online courses only to forget
everything you learned in just a few
weeks or maybe you've obtained an AWS
certification but not too sure what to
do next if you're feeling stuck on your
Cloud Learning Journey and want a
step-by-step plan to maximize your
chances of Landing a job then this video
is for you the reason most people find
it hard to learn a new technology or
finish an online course is because they
don't set a proper plan and I say this
because I've made the same mistake too
many times it's so easy to buy a 10
course and say to yourself I'm too busy
this week but it's okay I'll just come
back to it later later turns into never
and before you know it a few months go
by this year I'd encourage all of you to
break the cycle and remember one phrase
learn by doing the secret to learning
cloud computing in order to actually
land a job lies in this five-step plan
step number one get Cloud certified step
number two build hands-on experience
step number three tailor your resume
step number four prepare for interviews
and step number five Network and
showcase your skills many people I talk
to get stuck on step one and they spent
countless hours studying for
certifications even though obtaining a
certification can be a great addition to
your resume it's important to remember
that it's only one piece of the puzzle
research shows that 20 hours is the
magic number to become good at something
but if you spend all that time studying
for certifications you just become
really good at answering multiple choice
questions if your goal is to become one
of these roles simply knowing the theory
or being able to pass the certification
exam is often not enough to really stand
out you'll need to gain some hands-on
experience with building and deploying
applications in the cloud for example a
Solutions Arctic needs to build demos to
show customers Cloud Solutions with a
certification you'll be able to figure
out what to build but not really how to
build it which brings us to step number
two build hands-on experience there are
many ways to do this you could get an
internship build a cloud project or even
play around with cloud services but
sometimes to even land an internship in
the first place employers want to see
some sort of experience so my
recommendation would be to start by
playing around with cloud services and
then build two to three Cloud projects
projects serve two main purposes first
they can be added to your resume to show
potential employers that you have
Hands-On Cloud skills and second they
can be used as examples during
interviews allowing you to discuss your
experiences with building the projects
and any challenges you might have faced
if you're not too sure which projects to
build I have a video on my channel
explaining the top three Cloud projects
for beginners another project I'd
recommend looking into is the cloud
resume challenge it's pretty much a
project that walks you through how to
host your own resume on the cloud and
you can choose either AWS Azure or gcp
the project combines a few cloud
services and helps you build skills that
real Cloud Engineers use in their daily
work speaking of resumes it's important
to tailor your resume based on the role
you apply for one way to do this is by
creating a resume using an AI Resume
Builder an AI Resume Builder is pretty
much a tool that uses artificial
intelligence to create you a high
quality resume it can automatically fill
in your details helps you check for
grammatical errors and provides
suggestions on how to make your resume
better I wish I knew about AI resume
templates back when I was applying for
jobs because it would have saved me so
much time trying to manually tailor my
resume alright let me show you a quick
demo of how it works so I'm using resi
and AI Resume Builder platform with over
300 000 users once I sign up I can
select resume choose the Creator from
scratch and select the job tailored
resume option here you can see that I
can actually add in the entire job
description of the role I'm applying for
let's say I want to tailor my resume to
this associate Solutions Arctic role at
AWS I can pop in the job details and
copy and paste the entire job
description and then I'm asked to select
the industry and experience of the role
in this case it's an associate level
role now I need to spend some time
filling in some details about my
experiences projects certifications and
other relevant sections alright so I've
just filled in all my details and
straight away you can see that the
resume is ready to download food they
also have a bullet points feature to
help you rewrite specific dot points you
have in your resume and if you want to
write a cover letter rezzy can help with
that as well this video is sponsored by
rezzy so I'll leave a link down below to
the AR Resume Builder platform and if
you'd like to go with one of their paid
plans you can use the code Tech with
Lucy for 20 off all right so once you
create a tailored resume and start
applying to jobs the next step is to
prepare for interviews here are the five
areas I'd recommend focusing your
preparation on the first one is making
sure you review the job description and
requirements make sure you have a good
understanding of the specific
responsibilities and requirements of the
role is it a client-facing role or more
product based second area of preparation
is on the company you apply for what are
their main products and services what is
their company culture like for example
Amazon has 16 leadership principles that
are used as a foundation for their
culture these include customer Obsession
earn trust and think big so in the
hiring process candidates will be
assessed on how well they're live with
those principles third one is to compile
a list of the technical and
non-technical questions you might be
asked you can find this pretty easily
through websites like Glassdoor where
thousands of candidates share the
interview experience next step is to
practice the questions you've compiled
as well as common interview questions
like tell me a bit about yourself
remember that interviewing is a skill in
itself your ability to interact and
engage with an interviewer can be just
as important as all the qualifications
you have on your resume instead of
practicing a loan in front of a mirror
consider doing a mock interview where
you get a friend or family member to ask
you interview questions and provide you
with feedback and the final step is to
prepare a document of your projects and
previous career experiences in this
document you can write down specific
examples and include any metrics and
data points if you're looking for
technical interview questions I'd also
recommend checking out this video I made
where I talk about common Solutions
architect interview questions I've
interviewed a few candidates during my
time at AWS and one of the most common
mistakes I see is a lack of preparation
so make sure before interviews you cover
all five areas I just mentioned now the
most important step to this five-step
plan is actually the last one which is
the network and showcase your skills
when you build something cool share it
on LinkedIn if you want to talk to
others also interested in Cloud join an
online community the tech with Lucy
Cloud community on slack is a great one
to join by the way the main point of
this is to build a personal brand which
can lead to more career opportunities so
if you're just starting out I'd
recommend writing technical articles or
blog posts about your projects and then
publishing them on platforms like medium
or LinkedIn this will give you a place
to Showcase your skills and help attract
potential employers alright so those are
the five steps I'd recommend following
to learn a cloud role I've included a
whole bunch of other resources in the
description below so make sure you check
that out if you found this video helpful
please remember to give it a like and
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below hope everyone has an
amazing year ahead and I'll see you all
soon bye for now